Let's go next to just because we were
going to try a foreign call. Let's go to
Pete from Germany. Pete from
Germany. You're on the air.
Hi, can you hear me? Yes, I can. My name is
actually pronounced Peach, but it's it's Dutch,
although I have some property
that's allowed no problem.
OK, so my crystal ball boy should be is in Germany
on to far right, we have had the same problem said
to us with those normal white wing us who care
about the deficit or something like that. Yeah.
And with those Kuerten people who are
absolutely nuts, who think Donald Trump is
you, Jesus and such stuff, and my question
is how how can we fix it? How can we
get rid of those kind of people?
Because they are, as you can see
with the. With the casualty toll inspector.
Oh, my God. That properly and today they could
do a lot of talk to. You know, every country.
Oh, my God, this is a crazy connection. Pete,
are you blowing into the phone while slamming
it into a counter right now? No, you're not.
OK, listen, here's the deal. It
is a long term thing to fix that.
The the fact that the Republicans were primed
to fall for, like the Trump and Trump and Kuhnen
stuff doesn't happen overnight. It's been like
a 40 year programing in the United States. So
it will take a long time to do away with it.
And it comes down to education, epistemology,
cultural change. It's a big it's
probably a multi decade project.
So.
I was wondering that because
I know you have done also videos about how
this happened, but we have to stay here with,
you know, there is no Republican Party to party.
Well, yeah, all the Cubano people are hopped up,
popped up like eight years ago or something.
But you have Kuhnen in Germany, you're saying?
Yes. And that is my question.
How can we get rid of Cureton?
I mean, are they American Kuhnen
people who are in Germany?
I mean, their judgment, but they believe
the same stuff as the American people, they.
They also think Bill Gates is is
drinking the blood of people and
it's a great safe. Yeah, listen,
I don't know how to fix it.
I don't know how to fix it here and I don't know
how to fix it there. But it's disturbing that
you're also dealing with it, Pete.
Yes.
All right, Pete, thank you. It's an
unusual connection, but I was able to
ultimately understand the question and
I appreciate you calling in for sure.
Let's go next to. Where do we want to go? How
about Trey from Missouri? Trey, you're on the air.
Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
So I tried calling you last week
and it just didn't work. So I'm glad that
I was able to get on the air this time.
I'm glad to.
So obviously a big fan of the show,
I had a question about purity tests and sort
of litmus tests, I was watching one of the
political panels with you and Kasparian and Kyle
and Bakari and Meile. And one of the things that
I got out of it was the only real litmus test to a
president, to a candidate in any elected office is
whether they take corporate PAC money with sort of
inexperience, sort of kind of idea. Do you think
that that is good for all political candidates,
regardless of party and in particular on the left?
Do you think that that would be a winning strategy
is if we tell Democrats and Democratic leaning
candidates, stop taking corporate PAC money?
No, I listen, I. I don't that was a
couple of years ago. And did you say Milo
was on the panel? I don't remember that.
Maybe not someone someone else was on
the panel. I just want to read it was OK.
No, listen, I mean, the not taking corporate
PAC money is a great thing, and I love seeing
more candidates doing that. I don't think that
that is like the deciding line as to whether
someone is or isn't a good candidate. And there's
districts where that probably wouldn't even make a
difference. So, no, I I mean, listen, in politics,
there's very few like hard and fast rules.
And I want to get corporate PAC money out. We need
campaign finance reform. But no, it's not like the
be all end all. But it's a great thing. I think
in some places it won't make a big difference.
I just had a question about that. I just I know
that there are some people on the progressive left
who want that to be the end all be all standard.
Well, I don't I don't know who want who says that
that's the be all end all standard, Trey. But it's
certainly something to aspire to. I just don't
think at this point it's yet like a difference
maker or needs to be necessarily a litmus test
in all districts. All right. Thank you, David.
No problem. There is Trey from Missouri with
things not muted in the background, but
we're tolerating all of it, of course